Geof Astle Jimmy Hill Nat Lofthouse and
Billy McNeill some of the most famous
names in football history they all
suffered with neurodegenerative diseases
now a landmark study has shown former
professionals are far more likely to die
from these conditions the family of
former England footballer Jeff Estelle
has long fought to prove his death was
linked to heading of the ball this puts
them a step closer to that but offers a
little comfort the study compared the
health records of X professional
footballers born between 1900 and 1976
with the general population
it found that X footballers were three
and a half times more likely to have
died from neurodegenerative diseases
five times more likely to have died of
Alzheimer's disease and four times as
likely from motor neurone disease but
the report also showed that footballers
live on average over three years longer
and were less likely to die of heart or
lung disease throw the ball a little bit
higher and try to hit it on the same
spot off you go
the FA now issues advice on safe heading
of the ball the families of hundreds of
suffering players are now calling for
more support are you worried that there
could be legal challenges from from the
families no from our point of view the
families we've spoken to them they are
grateful and we've done the research
they're grateful that we're trying to
find an answer to this question that's
been around football for a long time we
actually are making them part of the
process moving forward experts want
further research to determine the risk
to modern-day players it is a
significant step forward I think it's
the first step and now we have that
evidence that shows that there is an
increased risk of dementia or dying of
dementia in X professional football
players now we can take the next steps
and really
understand through further research what
the reasons are underpinning this
increased risk an untold number of
players have died with neurodegenerative
diseases the hope is that this study may
prevent further tragedy Martha Kellner
Sky News